bran route to Indianapolis Indiana to do
some surprise poppins tonight and on
twitter i asked him buddy who should we
where should we go should we go to
someone's home and this one person on
twitter said yeah stop into my house we
decided let's do it let's go to
someone's house so we're doing it we're
pulling up to her house right now we're
gonna surprise her at her door with an
Oscar Oscar road trip baby Audrey zynga
right hello Ben glebe Oscar road trip
was your favorite movie this year ice
age ice age continental drift yes that's
one point on right now shut up really
look right there this is an extra bonus
surprise I'm in this movie wow you're
dead pagan yeah exactly that's my line
come on over and let's show you Oscar up
it's kind of heavy dude thank you so
much guy pleasure to meet you
people all over the country have been so
far just so excited about holding the
Oscar on that date they're huge movie
fans with movie that got me and fire the
bridden want dark spider-man people have
burst into tears that's just not from
when I walked up and looked at them
weird that was from the Oscar this is
amazing
great time in Chicago we went to the
factory where Oscar is made we got to
see every step from like the melting of
the metal to the mold to the dipping the
assembling the packaging every piece of
it is hand done by a person it was
really cool one of our Twitter followers
tweeted to us and asked us to come to
their hometown Mount Olive it's rural
Illinois outside of st. Louis when
somebody asks you to visit their rural
farm you say yes I mean it's rude not
we're on a farm we got a farm ever think
the Academy would recognize you for your
work and film touches the presence of
rise right considering you've never
worked in film I want to keep it well
yeah did you know he would become super
or did you just raise him like any old
boy any oh boy sure mind if i call you
mr. mrs. Kemp is that okay it's been an
amazing week every day gets better
Oscar rupture whoa th IC AG o that's how
you spell Chicago SI h I edgy
oh I kind of town